the exponential is no other word the
explosion of science and technology has
transformed not only our universities
but after they got enlightened it's the
very status of knowledge and of truth
the exact and Applied Sciences with the
inbuilt axiom of progress isn't it
fantastic we will know something
tomorrow which we did not know today
think of that for a moment even a
mediocre science a a keep will know
something next Monday which they did not
know today the escalator of science is
always moving upward they have created
new universities within the university
they are budget I don't need to say that
directors and Dean's but their budget
he's a hundred fold what was the budget
of the humanities in a ranking American
Ivy League university the cost of
controlling the temperature of the high
energy laboratory is now greater than
the cost of the entire university budget
ten years ago in ten short years in
science faculties salaries and prestige
far in excess of those who current in
non scientific departments I love to
point out Berkeley in California has a
faculty parking space and one part of it
is reserved for Nobel laureates part of
the parking space they have that many at
Berkeley just think of it biogenetic
seeks access
- the mechanism of life itself advances
in medicine are virtually
incommensurable and yet and yet met that
little French word met well the German
word Abba ABBA and yet our wars are as
barbaric as ever famine and enslavement
forced migration abound forty million
children are now near the hunger line
forty million children economics neither
foresaw nor is helping us in the present
crisis of late capitalism the mental
stress the sadness in the psyche the
criminality which characterized so much
of our urban and familial existence the
hysterical fright into narcotics and
hypnosis of the mass media have proved
proved resistant to scientific triumphs
and their cradle of enlightened
rationality in the age in the greatest
age science has ever known
there is more misery on our streets
there is more mental collapse than ever
before there is a stubborn enigma here a
partial answer may lie in the gap of
understanding which now separates
scientific knowledge and methods from
general and public routes you a Tilburg
are trying to handle this deep gap not
only as Galileo proclaimed does nature
speak mathematics but the evolution of
that language has excluded common sense
comprehension you and I still speak of
sunset and sunrise in a Ptolemaic use of
language sense
after Copernicus in Newton its of course
total nonsense
but we still use it continually we dwell
amid our take fictions of solid objects
this table we are told is a vortex of
electrons in quantum motion but the
causes may lie deeper science has since
Euclid prided itself on its ideological
and political abstentions on its
neutrality in respect of social and
political conflicts it has cultivated
what comes calls wonderfully
disinterestedness Noli Me Tangere I am
doing science don't interfere with
political or social concerns no limit on
glory its involvement in warfare or
Stalinist madness have been contingent
and self-destructive Heidegger god help
us put it with majestic insolence I
quote science does not think the person
shaft technique you had to be Heidegger
to be able to say that but it is it is a
very deep piece of idiocy the piece of
idiocy but it's very deep this is one of
the hardest things to handle deep
agencies do the humanities think the
proud phrase litter I human URIs the
Humane Letters mentor each guide
humanity who money does their condition
forgive me and I don't want to cause any
offence but their condition is not
resplendent a fair number of
undergraduates in self entitled universe
cities which are actually vocational or
trade schools promoted to a fake rank
verge on sub literacy I'm sorry